styliste et gérant de boutique depuis
quatre mois francky joseph est loin des
tumultes de son pays
sa mère vit là bas lui donne des
nouvelles à distance ils sont un pays
exsangue 80 à 95 pour cent des haïtiens
ne paient pas de taxes et si tu ne
paient pas de taxes comment les
présidents comment il va faire aussi
pour pour fait des hôpitaux consulter
hôpital pour pour comment dire au niveau
d'éducation comment il va faire pour
jouer tout ça je pense que
on vraiment un haïti a beaucoup de
choses à faire
un gouvernement devenu impopulaire
depuis la décision d'augmenter les prix
à la pompe source eux mêmes des
violences et malgré le rétropédalage
c'est la destitution du président qui
est demandée pour les ressortissants
le mal-être et ailleurs c'est un magasin
mignot puis au talent et au garage et
c'est sur la loi bouvard agi sous l'état
agissait son magasin une case et
magasins pillés magasin monde savamment
c'est nous qui vous changez pays assez
par président a changé bah non c'est pas
persuadé qu'à changer ces mentalités
nous c'est nous même pétition c'est plat
qui malade pour son analyse tienne si je
m'en fous dit c'est dit les optiques a
gardé sa maladie assez petacchi malade
qui causent pays à mon sens c'est à
chaque mais ils doivent notamment des
dépassements de départ et puis c'est pia
qui a trait et puis mali n'est pas qu'à
manger marie a soufflé aux convives non
non pauvreté extrême c'est pas normal
donc nous sommes tous nés sous sa encore
des papas casse et obliger casey musées
européens casey machine classé dans
l'est mais ça va quand même et non nulle
part a fait ça c'est nantes où eux ont
réussi à changer leur vie en quittant
leur pays
mais la gangrène dont souffrent haïti ne
l'a jamais vraiment quitté